(birds chirping)
- [Interviewer] All right, Samantha.
Samantha, where are you from originally,
where'd you grow up?
- [Amanda] I grew up in Las Vegas.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
You grew up with both your parents?
- I did not.
I grew up on the streets since I was 12.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What happened
at home that you ended up
on the street at 12?
- My best friend at the time, this girl,
her boyfriend came over and he
ended up doing meth with us.
I was young and so I ran away
when I did it that night with someone.
- [Interviewer] And your parents?
Who were you staying with, mom or dad?
- Then I was staying with
my grandmother and my mom.
- [Interviewer] And they let you go?
- Yeah, yeah.
They did report me missing a
lot, runaway, as a runaway.
- [Interviewer] Oh okay.
- A lot.
- [Interviewer] So you've
been on the street since 12?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- [Interviewer] And what
have you been doing?
How do you survive?
How do you support yourself?
- Back then I used to steal
cars, with my boyfriend.
We were together for
like eight years maybe,
but we used to go and
steal cars and stuff so.
But then I turned 19
and I was in Salt Lake
and I started escorting.
I was young, but I left Vegas to start,
which is kinda funny.
- [Interviewer] Salt Lake City escorting.
- Yeah, right.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about that.
- It was actually good, the
guys out there are very,
you know, they are
awesome, they support you.
- [Interviewer] That's nice (laughs).
Were drugs a part of your picture?
A part of the picture?
- Yeah, since I was 12, yeah,
I've been on drugs since then.
- [Interviewer] What drugs
have been your go too's?
- Meth and heroin, or pills,
I mean it's all the same really.
- [Interviewer] And what
are you using today?
- Meth I like today but
I would love downers,
I mean I just don't want to
get into that lifestyle again.
- [Interviewer] And where do you sleep?
Where do you stay?
- I live down in L.A, down on 54th.
- [Interviewer] So you have,
you actually have a roof
over your head?
- Yes, yeah, thank goodness.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been on the street?
Like in a tent?
- Yeah, recently, yeah.
Which sucks but I stopped
working and escorting
a few years ago so money's not as good.
- [Interviewer] How do
you support yourself now?
- I was dancing
but I don't do enough of it so.
- [Interviewer] So,
dancing at the strip club?
Why do you not continue with that?
- Why didn't I--
I'm still, I mean, I
still want to, I just,
not being mobile and
trying to figure out--
Oh, I was going into a
program, oh that's why.
I'm going to a program.
- [Interviewer] Oh you are?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I was just at one in Pacoima but yeah,
I did 45 days there.
- [Interviewer] Have you
done programs before?
- Only once.
- [Interviewer] And how'd that go?
- It was great, I got sober,
it's like eight years ago though.
- [Interviewer] What gets you to relapse?
- People, or my emotions,
like where I'm at,
people, places, and things they say right?
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
that's what they say.
Were there any childhood
events that kind of like
set you on this path you think?
Or why do you think
you're in this situation?
- Well, because this
is what life dealt me.
- [Interviewer] But I'm just
wondering if there was anything
in your childhood that
maybe kind of set this up?
- I don't know, probably,
I have had a bad childhood,
I don't like talking about it,
and I don't like thinking
about it so I just try not to.
- [Interviewer] Yeah drugs are a good way
of numbing yourself right?
- Yeah, yeah, it's sad.
- [Interviewer] And talking
about it is a good way
of fixing it.
- You think so?
- [Interviewer] I know so.
You wanna talk about it?
- I don't know, what's
there to talk about?
(speaking over each other)
- [Interviewer] Was there any abuse?
- Yeah it was abuse by my
mom, she used to beat me,
she hated me, I think it's
just 'cause she was jealous,
I don't know.
She never hit my brothers,
so that was really--
- [Interviewer] Only you?
- Only me yeah, yeah,
she would never hit them,
she loved them.
- [Interviewer] You got the a--
- The short end of a big stick.
- [Interviewer] Wow and was
there ever any sexual abuse?
- Yeah, when I was six
I lost my virginity to--
It was bad.
- [Interviewer] To who?
- To my stepdad's best friend.
He used to take me to "baseball" games.
- [Interviewer] Oh my God.
So it happened more than once?
- Oh yeah, for like a year and a half,
he was like showing me how
to be, how to be a lover.
Like he showed me how to
kiss, and he showed me how--
It was crazy and then he
would come over to the house
when my dad was making dinner
and he would sit in front
of my cousins, I feel bad now
'cause I didn't ever think about it
but I wonder if he molest--
He had to probably be molesting
my cousins at that point
'cause he would have me kiss
him and show them what I did
or what we did, what
we learned for kissing.
Now I can't stand saliva
because of that shit,
he had the wettest mouth, it was so gross.
It's weird because he would come,
it's my stepdads best friend
right, and he would come
and take me to games, to
baseball games, supposedly
but we, you know, we
would go to his trailer
and he would teach me how to
be, how to kiss, he taught--
That's how, okay, I
started humping (laughs),
sounds awful right?
But I started humping
everything because of him,
because he did something and he showed me
that when I pushed it or
whatever, that I would cum.
So I've been cumming since I
was six, like all the time.
I've been humping everything,
it's embarrassing.
Funny, but anyways, so he
used to take me to his trailer
and yeah, I used to do it in school.
It was funny, in fourth and
fifth grade I would just stand
on the edge of my desk and I'd just do it
in the middle of class so
that everyone in there--
I would cum all the time,
I'm serious, but anyways.
- [Interviewer] Was there
ever any other abuse?
- [Amanda] Yeah, he violated my, anal,
so it's fucking (laughs),
that's awful, and it kind of--
- [Interviewer] How old were
you when this was going on?
- [Amanda] Six.
After he did that, I hid behind the couch,
after that I was like, I
have to use the bathroom
and I hid and he found me back there.
He didn't molest me anymore after that.
- [Interviewer] He never got caught?
- [Amanda] Nobody, no, no.
- [Interviewer] Jesus.
- [Amanda] Yeah, and he was a teacher too.
- [Interviewer] You're kidding me.
- [Amanda] No, yeah, he was a teacher too,
- What grade?
- what a bastard.
High school actually.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
I mean, you know, he's
all right but not really.
- [Interviewer] You poor thing.
- You know, I was just
brought up a certain way,
if that's what they wanted me to do
then that's what they got.
- [Interviewer] Did your parents
ever find out about this?
- I don't know, I never
told anybody till I was 18
and then my grandma tried to
switch it around on my stepdad
and make him look bad, which was awful.
That was because she
used me that way for--
'Cause he was a great
dad, he was a great guy.
- [Interviewer] But his
friends were trouble?
- No, my stepdad, God no, no.
- [Interviewer] So who molested you?
- Oh right, oh I guess you're right, yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's what I'm saying,
(Amanda laughs)
his friends were trouble.
- Yeah, oh shit.
- [Interviewer] He might
have been a good guy
but his friends were not.
- I know, it's awful, one's pretty gross.
So I had never told anybody
'cause I didn't wanna
ruin anybodies lives.
- [Interviewer] And do you
think drugs are just a way
of kind of numbing that?
- Yeah, but also, because I
just like getting high now,
you know, it's just like, it's
just something I enjoy doing,
you know, pass the time, I like to kick it
and like, get high, that's
what I've got, you know.
So I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Do you see yourself
getting off drugs one day?
- I'm going to, I'm gonna go program.
I was supposed to already
be there honestly.
I just got my bottom teeth fixed, finally.
God, it looked so, it was awful.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah it was awful and
then it took like a year.
- [Interviewer] So what--
- So I was--
just so embarrassing.
- [Interviewer] Was it crystal meth that--
- Actually my ID, it is
horrifying, I mean, the picture,
every time I gotta pull it out,
I'm super embarrassed, oh shit.
- [Interviewer] Show me your ID.
- No (laughs) no.
- [Interviewer] I wanna see your ID.
- It's so bad, it's really bad.
- [Interviewer] (laughs) all
right we'll see about that.
- All right, yeah you can check it out.
- [Interviewer] All right, and
do you have kids of your own?
- No I don't, I wish,
I do not though, nope.
- [Interviewer] Is that
something you kinda foresee
happening one day?
- I would love to but I'm
getting old so I don't know.
Who would wanna bring
a kid in to this world
by the way though, it's
not very good here.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
You wanna be a little more stable
before you start doing that.
- Oh for sure.
Yeah, I would wanna give
the kid a good life,
not a shitty one.
- [Interviewer] Right.
Do you still have
contact with your family?
- Nope, they're all, they are all off
selling people out probably.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Do you have a boyfriend
or anything like that?
- Not right now, kind of, I'm
seeing someone okay, kind of,
but he's been getting real shitty
so I'm not okay with that you know.
It's like are you crazy?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's hard.
- Yeah.
Some men are just pains in the asses.
- [Interviewer] Yes, yes we are.
All right Samantha, well thank
you so much for coming in
and talking to me and--
- [Amanda] Sure.
- [Interviewer] Good
luck with your program.
- [Amanda] Yay.
(interviewer laughs)